impulsado por la subida de los precios
de la energía los gigantes del gas y la
gasolina de Francia han reportado
beneficios
récord total energis ha reportado más de
10.000 millones de euros en ganancias y
engie más de 5000 millones lo que ha
provocado nuevas peticiones de impuestos
extraordinarios ya que las facturas de
los consumidores siguen aumentando la
asamblea nacional rechazó la medida a
pesar de la presión de su oposición
no es normal que los franceses paguen
más para cubrir a los accionistas no
estoy en contra de que las empresas
obtengan beneficios pero aprovecharse de
una crisis es intolerable
entonces Europa algunos países ya están
obligando a pagar a los gigantes de la
energía Italia introdujo un impuesto del
25% sobre las empresas una medida
similar adaptada por el Reino Unido que
impuso un impuesto del 25% a los
gigantes del petróleo y el gas y España
también está considerando un impuesto
sobre los beneficios que se extenderá a
los bancos mientras que la izquierda
francesa lleva meses presionando para
que se aplique el impuesto a las
ganancias excesivas el gobierno
minoritario del presidente Manuel macron
está presionando a las empresas para que
hagan sus propios sacrificios para
ayudar al consumidor toda la ha reducido
los precios de la gasolina hasta finales
de año y Enya ha reembolsado 100 euros a
los clientes que reciben vales de
energía
estoy orgulloso de los resultados de
nuestras empresas francesas y
sorprendido de ver cómo se les echa la
hoy después de que hayan obtenido buenos
resultados los buenos resultados de las
empresas francesas son buenos resultados
para los franceses
el ministro de economía Bruno lemer
prefiera aumentar las ayudas a subir los
impuestos pero mientras el gobierno
minoritario se esfuerza por aliviar la
crisis del coste de la vida que se
agrava la oposición va a seguir
presionando